BRIAN: ALL RIGHT.
WE ARE BACK WITH A FOX NEWS
ALERT.
WE HAVE JUST LEARNED.
THIS BRITISH PRIME MINISTER
BORIS JOHNSON HAS TESTED
POSITIVE FOR THE CORONAVIRUS.
AINSLEY: TREY YINGST JOINS US
LIVE FROM OUR JERUSALEM BUREAU
WITH MORE.
TREY, THE PRIME MINISTER JUST
SPOKE ABOUT IT, RIGHT?
>> AINSLEY, BRIAN, STEVE, GOOD
MORNING.
THAT’S RIGHT.
WE ARE JUST LEARNING NOW THAT
U.K. PRIME MINISTER BORIS
JOHNSON HAS TESTED POSITIVE FOR
CORONAVIRUS, ANNOUNCED EARLIER
TODAY BY DOWNING STREET AND THE
PRIME MINISTER HIMSELF RELEASING
A STATEMENT SAYING THIS, QUOTE:
I’M NOW SELF-ISOLATING BUT I
WILL CONTINUE TO LEAD THE
GOVERNMENT’S RESPONSE VIA
VIDEO-CONFERENCE AS WE FIGHT
THIS VIRUS.
JOHNSON’S CONDITION IS WELL.
IS HE ONLY DISPLAYING SYMPTOMS.
ALL OF THIS HOURS AFTER BORIS
JOHNSON PARTICIPATED IN A G-20
SUMMIT CALL WITH WORLD LEADERS
INCLUDING PRIME MINISTER.
THAT CALL YESTERDAY JOHNSON
PLEDGING 210 MILLION POUNDS TO
DEVELOP A VACCINE FOR
CORONAVIRUS.
ALL OF THIS COMING AS JOHNSON
HAS NOW COMMITTED TO FIGHTING
THIS INSIDE THE U.K.
WE DO KNOW THERE IS CURRENTLY
MORE THAN 11,000 CASES IN THE
UNITED KINGDOM WITH MORE THAN
600 DEAD.
I DO WANT YOU TO TAKE A LISTEN
WHAT JOHNSON HAD TO SAY EARLIER
TODAY REGARDING THIS POSITIVE
DIAGNOSIS.
>> I HAVE DEVELOPED MILD
SYMPTOMS OF THE CORONAVIRUS
THAT’S TO SAY A TEMPERATURE AND
A PERSISTENT COUGH.
AND ON THE ADVICE OF THE CHIEF
MEDICAL OFFICER, I HAVE TAKEN A
TEST.
THAT HAS COME OUT POSITIVE.
SO I AM WORKING FROM HOME.
I’M SELF-ISOLATING AND THAT’S
ENTIRELY THE RIGHT THING TO DO.
>> PRIME MINISTER JOHNSON DOES
JOIN PRINCE CHARLES WHO TESTED
POSITIVE WHEN IT COMES TO THE
LIST OF NOTABLE BRITS WHO ARE
NOW FIGHTING THIS BATTLE
PERSONALLY.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE BROADER
PERSPECTIVE FOR THE UNITED
KINGDOM.
RIGHT NOW IN LONDON, THEY ARE
CONVERTING A LARGE EXPO CENTER
TOGO TO A MAKESHIFT FIELD
HOSPITAL.
500 HOSPITAL BEDS ARE GOING TO
BE PUT INTO THE CENTER IN AN
EFFORT TO TRY TO SLOW THE SPREAD
OF THE CORONAVIRUS IN THE UNITED
KINGDOM.
WE CAN EXPECT SOME CRITICISM FOR
JOHNSON TODAY WHO EARLY ON HAD
SOME POLICY DIFFERENCES WITH
SOME OF HIS TOP ADVISORS ABOUT
HOW EXACTLY THE UNITED KINGDOM
SHOULD APPROACH THE BATTLE OF
THIS VIRUS.
AGAIN, WHAT WE CAN CONFIRM TODAY
IS THAT THE UNITED KINGDOM PRIME
MINISTER BORIS JOHNSON HAS
TESTED POSITIVE FOR CORONAVIRUS.
HE WILL CONTINUE TO LEAD THE
EFFORTS IN THE U.K. TO FIGHT
THIS COVID-19 DISEASE IF IT DOES
CONTINUE TO SPREAD AND COUNTRIES